[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute wird's grün ich mache nämlich
pastor mit einer richtig leckeren
avocado soße und brokkoli das ganze
rezept dauert etwa 20 minuten also super
schnell gemacht mit nur ganz einfachen
zutaten für das rezept brauche ich 500
gramm nudeln ich nehme zählbar wette
vier esslöffel gehackte petersilie zwei
reife avocados eine unbehandelte zitrone
100 milliliter sahne eine knoblauchzehe
etwas salz und pfeffer ich habe hier
vier esslöffel olivenöl
hier habe ich 500 gramm brokkoli und für
burg olé brauche ich einen teelöffel
natron und etwas salz wasser ich habe
ich noch zwei esslöffel olivenöl und 200
gramm champignons und wer möchte nimmt
etwas parmesan bestreuen
wichtig ist jetzt am anfang dass ihr
gleich nudelwasser aufsetzt und einen
zweiten top für den brokkoli
ich werde es nämlich separat kochen ich
nehme jetzt zuerst mal den brokkoli und
kann den in röschen teilen
[Musik]
den strunk habe ich übrigens auch
geschält und den werde ich später
einfach mit verwerten
[Musik]
das nudelwasser kocht studien kann ich
jetzt zum garen reingeben und lasst sie
einfach nach packungsanleitung kochen
[Musik]
in den kleinen topf gebe ich jetzt
natron und salz um 26 für den brokkoli
damit er schön grün bleibt und den
blauen schwierig jetzt nur ganz kurz
also ich koche ihn kurz und so dass er
eben noch bis hat also etwa ein bis zwei
minuten und hier stelle ich jetzt gerade
die champignons in scheiben und wenn sie
dann in einer separaten pfanne in
olivenöl anbraten
die werden nämlich das topping
[Musik]
und jetzt muss ich mich beeilen die
nudeln sind nämlich gleich hier bereite
ich jetzt die grüne soße zu das heißt
hier kommt jetzt die petersilie dann die
avocado die könnt ihr halbieren und den
stein herausnehmen und biskup fleisch
dann mit einem löffel auskratzen
[Musik]
hier kommen jetzt auch zitronenschale
rein und deswegen ist wichtig dass die
unbehandelt ist und dann presse ich
gleich auf dem zitronensaft dazu
[Musik]
da kommt auch die saale mit rein dann
auch die knoblauchzehe salz und pfeffer
würzt durchführen und auch das olivenöl
und jetzt kann die soße kuriert werden
[Musik]
so jetzt gebe ich ein paar esslöffel von
moodle wasser hier zur sauce und kann
das mit einrühren und die nudeln auch
sofort abschließen
[Musik]
so jetzt kann alles zusammengefügt
werden hier habe ich jetzt die nudeln
und ich gebe immer gerne die soße direkt
mit dazu doch mal bitte was für die
fotos noch ein bisschen was für die
fotos dann schön vermischen
die soße müsst ihr natürlich abschmecken
ob genügend salz und pfeffer drin ist
dann den brokkoli mit rein den strunk
habe ich jetzt doch nicht hier mit rein
ich geben nämlich dann später in meine
brokkoli suppe mit rein aber wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr denn auch mit dazu
geben oder auch gerne mit pürieren und
jetzt kann ich schon servieren
[Musik]
und natürlich das topping die
champignons und wer möchte kann dann
noch ein bisschen parmesan darüber
reiben und perfekt und fertig ist das 15
bis 20 minuten gericht und daran einfach
nur noch genießen
und ich muss sagen ich liebe aber carlo
sowieso das ganze schmeckt ist so ein
bisschen wie guacamole auf nudeln total
lecker und brokkoli essen natürlich auch
super gesund hat viel kalium viel
kalzium vitamin d vitamin c und ist
natürlich immer schön grün
guten appetit ich lasse mir das jetzt
mit meinem team schmecken ich glaube ich
freu mich schon drauf
auf jeden fall wir machen noch ein paar
fotos für instagram und facebook und
natürlich für den block und dort findet
ihr auch das rezept auf sex - blog.de
ich freue mich aufs nächste mal viel
spaß dabei und zeigt uns auf jeden fall
eure fotos tschüss
[Musik]
[Applaus]